COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE CUPBOARD
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND GET
THAT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PROCEDURES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
YOU'LL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AGAIN.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN ONE AGAIN. ONE ONE
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN SEVEN ONE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. REMOVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE ON WHICH
YOU'RE WATCHING THE HEARING.
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO HEAR YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL ALSO MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IT'S
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
ARE HAD TO CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE USUAL. MANNER
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS TO
ADJUSTING T THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PETE PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IN
PATIENTS WHO ARE INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
ELEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
HOWEVER WE ARE NOT HEARING FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY SIX. WHICH HAS BEEN
DELAYED TILL THE NEXT HEARING.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
THE VICE CHAIR CENTERED
MELENDEZ IT WILL NOT BE PRESENT
FOR HEARING THIS AFTERNOON. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE NO MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS ARE UNDER
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY TWO
BY THIS- SENATOR COM LAGER. I
AM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER WOULD.
I AM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY ONE- BY THE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE. I AM
NUMBER TEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. AGAIN FROM THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE AND
ITEM NUMBER. ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. THOSE
BILLS. ARE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND WILL NOT BE HELD
HER TO MISTER X. THEY WILL NOT
THERE WILL BE TESTIMONY THOSE
BILLS IN LEICESTER EXTRACTED.
THE BILLS WILL BE HEARD IN FILE
ORDER HOWEVER THIS ORDER MAY BE
MODIFIED BECAUSE OF THE VEIL
ABILITY BILL AUTHORS TO
PRESENT. AND THE NEED TO
COMPLETE THE HEARING AGENDA. IN
A TIMELY MANNER. BEFORE THE
AGREEMENT OF ONE. OKAY BEFORE
WE HEAR PRESENTATION OF BILLS
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM FOR
TODAY'S HEARING CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I CAN
HEAR. MELINDA'S AIKMAN. A MAN
HERE CONSOLIDATES THOSE HERE
GROVE GROVE HERE HER TADO.
HURTADO HERE LLEVA YEAH LEAVE
IT HERE THE MON. ROTH WELFARE
RIGHTS HERE RUBIO YEAH RUBIO
HERE WINNER. HERE OKAY A QUORUM
IS ESTABLISHED THANK YOU. FOR
BILL TESTIMONY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
BILL TESTIMONY EACH IDE WILL
BE PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. HEARING HEALTH COMMITTEE
FOR THE PRIMARYWITNESSES A
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OUT FOR BID
UP TO TWO WITNESSES FOR TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS OUR MAXIMUM
OF FOUR MINUTES ON EACH SIDE
ALL OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS IN
HER NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE MEASURES. I HOPE TO HEAR
FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY TODAY HOWEVER BECAUSE
WE HAVE A DEFINITE END TIME FOR
THE HEARING I MAY LIMIT THE
TOTAL TIME FOR ALL COMMENTS ON
THE BILL TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO COMPLETE
OUR HEARING AGENDA TODAY.
EVERYONE ALSO HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT TESTIMONY
ON ANY BILL BEING HEARD TODAY
ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
SO THAT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH THE FIRST ITEM
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE. BY SUMMER
DAVIES WELL COME. UP PLEASE
BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR. SENATORS TODAY I'M
HERE TO PRESENT EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE. I WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS BILL.
WELL I STAYED HAS HAD TO DEAL
WITH THE GLOBAL HEALTH
PANDEMICS UNLIKE WE'VE EVER
SEEN BEFORE. IT CANNOT BE LOST
THAT PRIOR TO COPE IN NINETEEN.
THERE WAS ANOTHER HEALTH
EPIDEMIC SWEEPING OUR STATE.
I'M OF COURSE TALKING ABOUT THE
BATTLE WITH OPIOIDS. ACCORDING
TO THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL THERE WERE OVER EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND DRUG OVERDOSE
DEATHS NATIONALLY BETWEEN MAY
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND MAY TWENTY
TWENTY. THOSE WHO ARE BATTLING
THEIR ADDICTION TO THESE DRUGS
ARE ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE CLASS
OF VICTIMS IN ORANGE COUNTY WE
HAVE HEARD A DRUG DEALERS
SELLING NARCOTICS NEAR THE
GROUNDS OF DRUG TREATMENT
FACILITIES. OR WORSE MILITAR
CONTEXT TO THEM. TO HELP COMBAT
THIS EPIDEMIC ON MARCH FIFTH
TWENTY NINETEEN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCY. DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICE ISSUED INFORMATION
NOTICES NINETEEN DASH ZERO ZERO
NINE. THE FORMAL NOTICE NOW
IT'S THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC AN
AUTHORIZED DRUG TREATMENT
FACILITIES TO POSSESS AND USE
THE LOCKS ON ON SITE. WHEN
NEEDED HOWEVER THIS NOTICE DID
NOT REQUIRE DRUG TREATMENT
FACILITIES TO PURCHASE. NOR CAN
OR HAVE A STAFF MEMBER TRAINED
IN THE ADMINISTRATION OF
NALOXONE ONSITE AT ALL TIMES.
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY ONE IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE MEANT TO EXPAND
THAT FORMAL NOTICE BY REQUIRING
DRUG TREATMENT CENTERS TO
ACTUALLY CARRY. AT LEAST TWO
DOSES OF OVERDOSE MEDICATION ON
SITE LET'S HAVE A STAFF MEMBER
TRAINED HOW TO ADMINISTER IT.
IN CLOSING I BELIEVE THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
LITERALLY BEING. THE TOOL TO
SAVE THE LIVES OF AVAILABLE
CLASS OF PEOPLE. WITH THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS FOR DH CS
ON THE COMMITTEE THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
VOTE. WITH ME HERE TODAY VIA
PHONE IS JOHN TO FRESHLY WITH
THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH THANK YOU RESEARCH
AREAS YES OKAY WE HAVE FOUND
THE FIRST YEAR READY ON THE
LINE RIGHT A POLICE BEGAN- TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU SO MUCH- THE
TENDERS. MY NAME IS SHANTI
PRECIO A PROSECUTOR AT THE
CENTRE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WHERE I SERVE
AS THE ASSISTANT CHIEF OF OUR
MAJOR NARCOTICS DIVISION. I'M
HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE EIGHT
ONE. ONE OF OUR AREAS OF FOCUS
IS THE PROTECTION OF CHEMICALLY
DEPENDENT NARCOTICS USERS WHO
ARE INJURED BECAUSE OF THE
INFLUX OF DANGEROUS OPIOIDS
INCLUDING FENTANYL WHICH IS
FIFTY TO ONE HUNDRED TIMES MORE
POTENT THAN MORPHINE. YOUR DESK
ARE SKYROCKETING IN OUR NATION
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS CURRENT
PANDEMIC. FOR THE TROUBLING
TRENDS WE'VE SEEN INVOLVES A
RISE IN OVERDOSES AND DRUG
TREATMENT FACILITIES. ASIANS
RECEIVING TREATMENT AT THE
CENTERS FIND WAYS TO ACCESS
OPIOIDS. THE RISK OF OVERDOSE
IS ESPECIALLY HIGH WITHIN THESE
FACILITIES THAT PATIENT DRUG
TOLERANCE DECREASES AFTER
PERIODS OF SOBRIETY. THIS RISK
IS COMPOUNDED BY THE FACT THAT
SENTINEL QUIETLY CONTAMINATES
THE ILLICIT DRUG SUPPLY. MOST
COMMONLY WE'VE SEEN IT DEADLY
COUNTERFEIT OXY CODE ON PILLS
S. AS PURE FENTANYL. NALOXONE
ALSO KNOWN AS IN OUR CANDIDATE
CHEAP AND EFFECTIVE DRUG THAT
REVERSES THE EFFECTS OF AN
OPIOID OVERDOSE. QUITE SIMPLY
IT SAVES LIVES WITH A SIMPLE
SQUARE IN THE NOSE. THE VERY
FIRST RECOMMENDATION ARE CDC
PROVIDE AS IT RELATES TO OPIOID
OVERDOSE MEDICATION IS TO
QUOTE. EXPAND DISTRIBUTION AND
USE OF NALOXONE AN OVERDOSE
PREVENTION EDUCATION ENCLOSED.
STATES SUCH AS CONNECTICUT
MASSACHUSETTS WISCONSIN AND NEW
MEXICO HAVE CODIFIED THE
MANDATORY DISTRIBUTION OF
NALOXONE TUBAL NORMAL PATIENTS.
WE SHOULD DO THE SAME BY
REQUIRING THAT DRUG TREATMENT
FACILITIES POSSESS TO UNEXPIRED
DOSES OF NALOXONE SO THEY CAN
EFFECTIVELY TREAT THEIR MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS ON THE
VERGE OF DEATH. AB THREE EIGHT
ONE WILL SAVE LIVES. BECAUSE OF
THAT I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THIS NO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY ONE
BEGINNING WITH- THE PUBLIC
GALLERY HERE IN THE CHAMBER
SEEN ON THE PUBLIC GALLERY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SCENE ON ONE TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES TO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE AGAIN IT'S
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE
EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THING ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL.
BE WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND
PLACE IT BACK IN THE QUEUE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE
EIGHTY ONE. THIS PRESS ONE
THING THERE ARE NOW. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE THREE PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE.
RIGHT PLEASE BEGIN- I NUMBER
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PLAYER ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
DCSO SHOULD SAY THERE ARE
MOMENTS IN THE OTHER TAKING
THOSE- SERVICES GO DEPARTMENT
OF. HEALTH WOULD STILL LIKE THE
TYPES OF FACILITIES. IN THE
BILL EXPANDED IF POSSIBLE BUT
STRONG SUPPORTOF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THANK YOU MESSAGE
AIRLINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I AM. THE TITLE WITH THE
COUNTY BECAME A HELP DESK
TECHNICIAN- WE WENT TO THE
AMENDMENT WE THANK THE AUTHOR
AND MOVE ON WE REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION POSITION AND MOVED
TO COURT POSITION ON THE BILL
THANK. YOU RIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. THANK YOU MISTER TERRILL
NUMBER EIGHTEEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN VERSUS IT'S
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
SPECIFICATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU FOR
SIGNING UP. AND AT THE TIME OF
DAY CARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION- LISTED- SO WILL
THEN GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION BEGINNING WITH
PUBLIC GALLERY SING ON THE
PUBLIC GALLERY LET'S MOVE
THROUGH TWENTY FORTY SCENE NO
ONE ONE TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO ANY
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MR
TERRIBLY DETERMINED IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THEIR
LINE NUMBER. AND PLACE YOU BACK
INTO THE QUEUE. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE- NOW. AND
IT IS COMMENTED HERE WE HAVE NO
ONE Q. OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
LET'S NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY YES- CENTER GROVE I'M OF
THE BILL. OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER GROVE- SEEING NO ONE
ELSE I JUST WANT TO SAY- SUMMER
DAVIS- FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WORKING WITH THAT
PART OF HEALTHCARE SERVICES
TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS. I WOULD
MAKE NOTE JUST BRIEFLY AND THE-
ANALYSIS- AND I REALIZE THAT
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH RECORDS OF
NOW- REMOVE DROPS YOU'RE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THEY DID
MAKE IT IS NOTED THAT- IT'S
UNCLEAR. WHAT SITUATIONS WOULD-
IN ADMINISTERING NALOXONE AND
WOULD BE CONSIDERED GROSS
NEGLIGENCE OR WILLFUL
MISCONDUCT I KNOW THOSE WERE
NOT NECESSARY PART OF THE
ORIGINAL BILL- IT'S ALSO A
TOPIC THAT PERHAPS WILL BE
ADDRESSED BY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHICH THIS BILLS
COMING FORWARD BUT I'LL JUST
SAY AS A CLINICIAN I. DO AGREE
WITH THAT STATEMENT DOESN'T
QUITE MAKE SENSE TO ME WHY WE
WOULD PUT THAT LANGUAGE WHICH
MAY ACTUALLY DISCOURAGE PEOPLE
FROM ADMINISTERING NALOXONE
WHICH IS COUNTER TO I KNOW THE
GOALS OF YOUR BILL- I GUESS
I'LL LEAVE IT TO JUDICIARY TO
DEAL WITH THAT. I APPRECIATE
YOU BRING FORWARD THAT THIS
BILL AND SEARCH THE EARTH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU SO THE EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE SPIN MOVE BY CENTER
GROVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY- CANCELED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HAND HI. CAN I
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN EIGEN
SOLACE HI THEMSELVES I GREW I
GREW I HER TADO I RETIRED- I
LISA HI. LISA MON. BROTH HI.
ROTH I RUBIO. HI RUBIO. I
WINNER. WINNER I. SO THE BILL
CURRENTLY IS NINE ZERO BUT THE
BILLING CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY- NEXT ITEM WOULD BE
ITEM NUMBER. FOUR BY THIS IS
DECEMBER BERIKAN HERE YET. IF
SHE ISN'T UP. THERE YOU ARE
SORRY. OKAY SO THE EXAMS I'M
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE BY SOME MEMBER BERIKAN.
RIGHT WELCOME THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AN EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE A SIMPLE YET
MEANINGFUL ADDITION TO ONE WORD
IN THE CODE THAT THE NON BINARY
GENDER OPTION ON DEATH
CERTIFICATES THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY AND PARTICULARLY THE
TRANS AND NON BINARY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE LONG WRONG
LONG FOUGHT FOR RECOGNITION AND
EQUALITY UNDER THE LAW. AT THIS
VERY MOMENT THEIR RIGHTS ARE
BEING ATTACKED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH BANDS ON VITAL
HEALTHCARE AND SPORTS
PARTICIPATION IN MANY OTHER
STATES. I AM SO PROUD TO BE A
PART OF THIS LEGISLATURE IT IS
MADE CALIFORNIA A LEADER IN
PROTECTING LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE
AND THEIR RIGHTS TO LIVE IS
THEIR FULL SELVES. PROTEIN
ATKINS HAS LONG LED THIS FIGHT
WITH THE B. FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
GUARANTEEING THAT SEX WOULD
REFLECT GENDER IDENTITY ON
DEATH CERTIFICATES. THAT'S THE
ONE SEVENTY NINE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH ALLOWED
CALIFORNIANS TO IDENTIFY AS
MALE FEMALE OR NON BINARY. ON
BIRTH CERTIFICATES DRIVER'S
LICENSE IN COURT DOCUMENTS.
THIS BILL EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE BUILDS ON THIS CRITICAL
WORK BY ADDING NON BINARIES AN
OPTION ON DEATH CERTIFICATES.
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO NOT IDENTIFY
AS MALE OR FEMALE ARE
CONSTANTLY FORCED TO JUSTIFY
THEIR EXISTENCE AND ARE DENIED
THEIR OWN IDENTITY EVEN IN
DEATH. PRONOUNS IN GENDERED
LANGUAGE MATTER NON BINARY
YOUTH WHO REPORTED THEIR
PROGRAMS WERE NOT RESPECTED BY
THOSE IN THEIR LIVES WERE TWICE
AS LIKELY TO ATTEMPT SUICIDE AS
THOSE WHOSE CORRECT PRONOUNS
WERE USED. SUICIDE RATES
AMONGST NON BINARY USE
QUADRUPLE THOSE OF THEIR PEERS
AFFIRMING LANGUAGE ON DEATH
CERTIFICATES IS ALL THE MORE
ESSENTIAL BECAUSE OF THIS. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR TAMMY MARTIN LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR QUALITY CALIFORNIA
AND SAM BRINTON ADVOCATE WITH
THE TREVOR PROJECT. THANKS VERY
MUCH A MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ON THE LINE TIM MARTIN FROM A
QUALITY COST FORMULA AND SAM
BRITAIN FROM THE TREVOR
PROJECT- I THINK WE'LL BEGIN
WITH TAMMY MARTIN YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
TOGETHER I'LL GIVE IT TWO
MINUTE WARNING FOR THE FIRST
THAT. TEST THE FIRE- SO YOU
KNOW WE GET TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BUT THE
COUNTY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA- I'LL BE
BRIEF. WE'RE VERY PROUD TO BE A
CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE WHICH OTHER AUTHOR
DESCRIBED. REALLY BUILDS ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S PREVIOUS WORK-
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
NON BINARY CALIFORNIANS HAVE
THE FREEDOM TO LIVE. AND HE
REMEMBERED AS THEIR AUTHENTIC
SELVES SO THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE UPDATE THE CODE AND IT
WILL HELP TO RELIEVE SOME
MEASURE OF THE PAIN THAT PEOPLE
FEEL WHEN THEY'RE NON BINARY
LIKE ONE. BY ENSURING THAT
THEIR OFFICIAL DOCUMENTS ARE
BOTH RESPECTFUL AND ACCURATE
THANK YOU I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MAITLAND AND- THANK YOU SAM
BRITAIN. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MY NAME IS SAM BRINTON YOU'D
PAY AND THEN MY PHONE UP AS A
NON BINARY INDIVIDUALS WE
BELIEVE THE FACT REMEMBER AND
WHY DID BUT FORTIN I WOULD
MENTION BEFORE. MORE THAN HALF
OF FRANCE AND NON BANK. THEY'RE
THINKING THAT THAT. TO INVITE
IN THE PAST YEAR AND- THEN. NOT
VERY NEAR YOU HAVE THEIR PHONE
NUMBER. BY THE PEOPLE IN THE
LINE I SUICIDE HAVE THE RIGHT.
DID NOT HAVE. THE WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE- I'M NOT BE UNDER THAT
NON BINARY PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
DO THAT IMPORTANT PART ABOUT
LEGAL. REPORTER GET THE LOWER
RATE OF ATTEMPTING. OBVIOUSLY
THAT THAT IF I WERE ALL MAKING
SURE THAT WE GIVE. IT WOULD BE
READY TO ACT BUT I'M GREAT AT
THE CORPORATE. ONE OF THE WAYS
WE CAN DO THAT WILL BE BUT NOT
BY THEM ARE GIVING THOSE TYPE
OF DOCUMENTS NEEDED TO BE
APPLIED SO I REALLY HOPE THAT
YOU WILL NOT WORK FOR IT ON THE
PLAYSTATION. I'M OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE BEGAN WITH PUBLIC GALLERY
SCENE ON THE PUBLIC I WAS MOVED
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY C. KNOWN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR.
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR THIRTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. THANK YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW.
UNLIMITED YEAH WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE COMING UP. THANK. WHAT
MESSAGE ARE GATHERING THEIR
LINE NUMBER OKAY. JUST GRABBING
THAT NUMBER NOW ONE MOMENT.
MMHM. THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THE
GERMAN LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
CAROLINA APPEARED ON BEHALF OF
A TELL YOU HOW I ACTED. IN
SUPPORT. RIGHT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. AT THE TIME THAT YOU'RE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO LEAD OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY. THERE'S ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY IS MEANT TO RUN TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES TO WITNESSS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY NINE AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION A BABY BOY
THIRTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PLACE
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN. BUT
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. IN AT THE TIME
OF DAY CARE WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU LET'S NOW
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- CENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
SORT OF THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL AND FOR-
STANDING WITH. HER COMMUNITY
AND BEING A GREAT ALLY AND I'M
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL. RIGHT
BUILD A NEW BY CENTER WINNER IS
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE OF THAT
WELL I GUESS SENATOR RUBIO
SORRY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT
SPECIALLY STATED IT'S SUCH A
SIMPLE BUT STILL MEANINGFUL.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND I
THINK THAT- THEIR DEATH
CERTIFICATES REALLY SHOULD
REFLECT HOW THEY LIVE THEIR
LIVES AND YOU KNOW THAT GIVES
THEM DIGNITY RESPECT AND IT'S
REALLY A REFLECTION. OF HOW
THEY LIVE THEIR LIVES SO I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE- CON AT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
I'D REALLY APPRECIATE-
IMPORTANCE OF- THE SPELL AND-
CERTAINLY IN SUPPORT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR SUPPORT AND TELL THESE
REALLY I'D BE HONORED TO HAVE
HER AS A CO AUTHOR AND RESPECT
FOR ASPIRIN. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH SO- THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED
BY. A CENTER WINNER TO MOTION
IS DO PASS. CONTROL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL HAND BY HAND HI
MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN EIGEN
SOLACE. HI CONSOLES I GROVE.
TATO HI. HURTADO HI LISA HI
LISA I LI MON HI LIMONEIRA
ROTH. ROTH I RUBIO HI RUBIO I
WINNER WINNER I. THE BILLS
CURRENTLY- NINE ZERO OR HOLD
THE BILL OPEN THANK YOU ON CALL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY ONE I SUMMER
RAIN BILL- AND IF THEY'RE CLEAN
THE PODIUM I JUST ONE REMINDER-
PLEASE BE SURE THAT YOU MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING- THE
HEARING ON IF YOU'RE GIVING
TESTIMONY FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE GIVING THE TEST MAY
REMOTELY I THINK WE GOT PICKED
UP A LITTLE BIT OF A- FEEDBACK
LOOP THERE- WILL EARLIER SO
JUST AGAIN A REMINDER WHEN YOU
DO GIVE TESTIMONY. ON A BILL ON
PLEASE REMEMBER TO MUTE THE
DEVICE ON WHICH YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON OKAY WITH THAT-
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A SIMILAR
RAMBLING IN PERSON IN LIFE
HERE- WHICH LIKE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY ONE WILL
REMOVE BARRIERS IN CURRENT LAW
TO ENSURE AN INDIVIDUAL SEEKING
EMERGENCY PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES
HAS TIMELY ACCESS TO THE
DISHING CARE. AND SERVICES THAT
MAY BE NEEDED. WHY MANY OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS IN A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS MAY SEEK CARE AT A
NEAREST EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
AFTER EVALUATION BY AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN SOME
INDIVIDUALS NEED ADDITIONAL
PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES. AND
REQUIRE TRANSFERRED TO A
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL. HOWEVER
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS HAVE
EXPERIENCED TROUBLE
TRANSFERRING PATIENTS TO
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES. THAT DO
NOT MAINTAIN AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. THERE IS A CONCERN
THAT SOME PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS
ARE USING LANGUAGE IN CURRENT
LAW. WHICH ONLY APPLIES TO
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS. THAT
MAINTAIN AND OPERATE AN E. D.
AS A WAY TO NOT ACCEPT ALL
PATIENTS OFTEN BASED ON THEIR
PERCEIVED INABILITY TO PAY. IF
A PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL AVOIDS
TAKING PATIENTS IT LIMITS
ACCESS TO CARE AND REDUCES
CAPACITY OF ALREADY SCARCE
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES. CARE
SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
PATIENTS FACING AN EMERGENCY
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS REGARDLESS
OF THEIR ABILITY TO PAY. EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY ONE PROVIDES A
CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS TO
PATIENT ACCESS TO PSYCHIATRIC
TRANSFERS BY REQUIRING ALL
HOSPITALS TO ACCEPT HIGHER
LEVEL PSYCHIATRIC TRANSFERS
REGARDLESS OF A PATIENT'S
ABILITY TO PAY. I'M JOINED
TODAY BY TEN MADDEN LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND
TERRA GAMBLE EASTMAN OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE. THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH- MODERATE
PLEASE BRING ON TO THE LINE OR
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TEN
MAN FROM CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
INTERROGATE HIM BUT YES MEN
FROM STEINBERG INSTITUTE EACH
OF YOU. HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER SO THIS
MAN IF YOU GO OVER I'LL GIVE
YOU TWO MINUTE WARNING BUT THEN
THAT TAKES UP THE- THE OTHER
PERSON'S TIME SO- WE HAVE
MISTER IF WE HAVE TO MAN ON.
THE LINE PLEASE BEGIN. GREAT
CRICKETER NUMBERS TONIGHT
REPRESENTING REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS. DR EMILY DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB IN OUTLINING. THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL AND THE
SITUATION EMERGING HERE FOR
THIS ARE FACING. TODAY IN OUR
CHALLENGED WITH TRANSFERRING
PATIENTS TO PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITIES. SHOULD THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
IN YEARS PAST. ACTUALLY ASKED
ABOUT. THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON
TO TERRA GAMBLE WHAT YOU SPEND
FROM STANFORD IT'S A TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE TARGET IN THE EVENING WITH
A FINE BURGUNDY. WE'RE AN
INDEPENDENT NON PROFIT PUBLIC
POLICY IN. WELCOME TO JAPAN
SOUND PUBLIC POLICY AND
INSPIRED LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE SURROUNDING BRAIN HEALTH
JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS ONGOING
COMMITMENT CONTRACT INITIATE
THE BRAIN HEALTH AND TOBACCO
REGULAR. FOR OUT. OUR THANK YOU
I TOOK A MERGING BECAUSE FAULT
LOCAL SHORT OF PROVIDING CARE
TO THE- FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT THE
ONLY PLACE THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T
PULL IT BACK HERE.
INTERMITTENTLY DEPARTMENTS
REALLY THIRD IS THE ENGINE
WENT. NUMBER INDIVIDUAL CAN
AFFECT THE HIGHER LEVELS. OF
CARE THAT THEY NEED AND DESERVE.
IN TO LIFT IT HOWEVER PATIENTS
TO BE TRANSFERRED THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU. THE LADY.
RIGHT NOW PATIENTS ARE
LANGUISHING IN OUR REGION.
ESPECIALLY MEDIC HELP PATIENT
BECAUSE SOME PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITY. BASED ON THEIR
INSURANCE STATUS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE SHOULD NOT BE
LOCKED AWAY FROM THE NEEDED
PSYCHIATRIC. APPLICABILITY YEAH
AT THEIR MEDICARE ENROLLEES FOR
UNINSURED. ALL THE DETAILS BUT
THE TIMER INSTITUTED THROUGHOUT
THE FOUR EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY ONE
ACTUALLY. REQUIRE I DOUBT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL
NOW MOVE ON TO DISH NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY ONE PM PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON THE PUBLIC
GALLERY LET'S MOVE THROUGH
TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF.
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY ONE AGAIN
NAME WORKSTATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU AT THE CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK AT THE POINT OF EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. THANK YOU BACK AND YOU.
CAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE- NOW. AND AT THIS TIME
BUT HERE WE HAVE NO ONE Q. OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH WE'LL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE OPPOSITION WE DO
HAVE. A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
TYLER ROB. RYAN I THINK FROM
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. SINCE THE
SUPPORTERS THAT HAVE TWO
WITNESSES FOR UP TO FOUR
MINUTES WE'LL GIVE YOU TOTAL
FOR UP TO FOUR MINUTES. IF YOU
WISH LET'S BRING ON- TELL
AROUND. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
PARENT J. I'M CHECKING IN AND
MEMBERS ARE BUSY WITH. CORRECT
BUT BOTH THE AGE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FORTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BRANDYWINE I WOULD BETTER MY
COMMENTS TODAY AROUND THE
INCLUSION OF PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH
FACILITY THEN THE LEGISLATION.
AND REQUIRING THAT THE FACT
THAT WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT
PRIVATELY INSURED INDIVIDUALS
WILL NEGATIVELY IMPACT MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES. BROADER COUNTY
PUBLIC. IT THE INCLUSION OF
BAGHDAD HELP THE THAT WE NEED
TO MY MARRIAGE- MEDIC HOW
BETTER. UNDER DIFFERENT.
LEGISLATION MAY IMPACT THE
VIABILITY OF THE FACILITY.
TWENTY NINE OF THE THIRTY THREE
BUT THAT WOULD BE THE CROP IT
HAD BEEN BAD. AFTER ALL I AM
YOU BELIEVE PROHIBITING MATTER.
FUNDING FOR FACILITIES WITH
OVERSIGHT AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE A CLIENT FROM JAIL TO
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS ANOTHER
SPENDING. AGAIN TO HELP
FACILITY HI OVERHEAD. AND ARE
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO CREATE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE.
ADDITIONALLY LIMITED IN THE
REIMBURSEMENT AND FINANCING
STRUCTURES. ARE NOT AUTOMATIC
HELP TOWARDS THAT AND ONE
INDIVIDUAL WITH PRIVATE
INSURANCE. IN ONE OF THE
FACILITY THEY CAN OFTEN KNOCK
BLACK HOLE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THEIR COSTS FROM THE PRIVATE
INSURANCE PLANS. WHICH WILL
LEAD TO COUNTY AND HAVINGTO
SUBSIDIZE THE COST OF CARE
PROVIDED A PRIVATELY INSURED
INDIVIDUALS REDUCING FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. BILL. AND IT YOU
KNOW YEAH I CAUGHT- CLOCK THAT
IDENTICAL PATELLA. THAT ON MY
COUNTER AND A LOT AN ATTEMPT TO
GO. ERICOM ME- ALL THE NOW PAD
I GET KICKED TO IS RUN AT A
VERY HIGH ARE. AND ARE ARE ALL
BY REQUIRING FIDEL TO ACCEPT
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT REGARD FOR
ENSURING THAT IT. BILL WILL BE
THE MEDIC HOW BENEFICIARIES
BEING PLAYED IN HIGHER
PROFITABILITY THE OVER SIXTEEN
BAD COUNTY FUNDING FOR
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALIZATION
UNDER NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT AT THE SAME LEVEL
AS YOU'RE NOT GOING TO WORK.
WITH AN INCREASE IN NEED
ESPECIALLY. DURING THE NINETEEN
AND I. HOW IMPACT. BILL IS ALSO
BACHELOR CONCERN TEAM AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE PROJECT THE
MINISTRATION AND PROPOSING TO
TERMINATE CONTRACT FOR COUNTY
FOR CONSERVATIVE EVEN AT THE
HOSPITAL- CRYING COUNTY
TRANSACTION SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT INDIVIDUALS TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE EXTREMELY HIGH RANKING HIGH
IN FIBER TO OTHERS GET HER
MENTAL ILLNESS. THERE ARE NO
PLACEMENT AVAILABLE AT THE
LOCAL. LEVEL FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS. SHE THOUGHT THAT
MIGHT HAS RICH. THE CONTRACTED
IN. PROPOSAL IN THE ACTION
TAKEN. BRING THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OF MINE WE HOWEVER
NEGOTIATIONS ARE ONGOING
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE AND THERE'S STILL
AN OUTSTANDING LOCK. ON YOU
KNOW MANY INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL POPULATION THE BILL IS
CONCERNING IF THIS PROPOSAL
GOES FOR YOU. OR SOME VARIATION
OF IT AND COUNTY FOR ME TO PLAN
FOR TAKING HOME. SOME OF THEIR
OBJECTIVITY THE DEBATE HOSPITAL
AND ALL LOCAL CAPACITY WILL BE
NEEDED TO READY TO ACCEPT THE
INDIVIDUAL. BY REQUIRING POT
AFTER TOPIC BILITY TOOK THAT
OUT OF NETWORK PRIVATELY
INSURED INDIVIDUALS NOT
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THE FINANCING.
THE I AM THE EXCLUSION AND
EXPECTATION THAT COUNTIES WILL
NEED TO TRANSITION HALLMARK
READ FULL ARTICLE HIGH RISK AND
HIGH NEED POPULATION OF CONCERN
AT THE- PARTY THE REASONS WE
REMAIN OPPOSED IN RESPECT. OF
YOUR CRAP AND KNOW ABOUT THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU NOW MOVE ON TO
THIS WITNESSES AND OFTEN. TO
EIGHTY FOUR ONE PM PUBLIC
GALLERIES ON THE PRO GALLERY
IT'S MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
C. KNOWN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR. PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES TO WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TWO
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY ONE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MEDICARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHT FORTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH EVEN MY NUMBER I THINK-YOU'RE BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THING
THERE ARE NOW. AND AT THIS TIME
OF YEAR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OR THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
US. SENATOR ADMIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I GUESS I WOULD LIKE
TO GIVE A DOCTOR RANDALL A- AN
OPPORTUNE TO RESPOND TO THE
OPPOSITION- BUT I WOULD
CERTAINLY SAY. THAT I THINK I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT WE NEED
TO WORK REALLY HARD. TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF BED
SPACE THAT WE HAVE ACROSS OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM. AND THE WHOLE
SYSTEM NEEDS A REHABBING AND I
THINK THIS IS A WAY TO BE ABLE
TO BEGIN. HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
GOING. ON GOING SO I LIKE TO
GIVE HIM A CHANCE JUST TO
RESPOND TO THAT BUT ALSO- LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL. WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT AND- AND THIS IS IN
SOME RESPECTS REMINDS ME OF A
BILL THAT I WORKED ON FOR YEARS
BUT COULD NEVER MOVE VERY FAR
WAS. THE IDEA OF A BED REGISTRY
ACTUALLY KNOWING OR PSYCHIATRIC
BEDS ARE- BUT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF RESISTANCE TO HAVE
PEOPLE PUTTING THAT WHICH SEEMS
PRETTY BASIC ONLINE- SO. IN
MOVING THE BILL I WOULD ASK
DOCTOR RANDALL IF YOU'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT IT BEING TOO
MUCH AT THIS TIME. OKAY SO THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
ADMIN AND- THE- THE SELLER AND
RANDALL WHICH LIKE THE ANSWER.
THANK YOU AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE
THE DOCTOR RECOMMEND ON THE RED
CARPET I THINK THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME I SEE YOU IN YOUR
NEWPOSITION AND JUST WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU FOR THAT.
FIRST AND FOREMOST C. B. H. T.
A.'S OPPOSITION APPEARS TO BE
BUDGETARY IN NATURE. IT'S MORE
FOCUSED ON. HOW WE REACH THE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE AND ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF LACK OF BED SPACE.
RATHER THAN THE POLICY THAT
THIS BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO
SOLVE. WHICH IS IF THERE IS A
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE. ARE WE
ABLE TO TRANSFER THAT PATIENT
BASED ON THAT PLEASE. WHICH IS
THE REAL TEST. OF THE POLICY
THAT'S BEFORE YOU HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU MR GROVE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT AND I KNOW THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN PREVIOUS
VERSIONS IN THIS BILL- OVER THE
PAST YEARS HAVE BEEN THE
ORIGINAL VERSIONS NEVER
INCLUDED AT THE PSYCHIATRIC
HEALTH FACILITIES SO I DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOLLOW UP
ON MY- CALLING FROM STOCKTON'S
COMMENTS WHICH- I THINK WE HAVE
THE SAME CONCERN MAYBE NOT AT
THE SAME LEVEL BUT THE SAME
CONCERN. I AS OPPOSITION STATED
AND THEN YOUR RESPONSE WAS IS
THAT- IT WOULD SEEM TO BE
PURELY BUDGETARY. I DO HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE I WE HAVE
LIMITED BEDS IN KERN COUNTY
TULARE COUNTY IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY. AND IF THIS BILL PASSES
WHICH I THINK IS A REALLY GOOD
BILL I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT IN
THE FIRST PLACE I THINK IT'S A
GOOD BILL I DON'T THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD BE. REQUIRED TO PROVE
THAT PAYMENT SOURCES BEFORE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY TREATED.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. AND
I HAVE DOCTORS THAT TALKED TO
ME- ALL THE TIME AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FALLING ALL THE
TIME ABOUT NOT BEING ABLE TO DO
FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLDS NOT BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE MEDICATION.
BECAUSE THEY'LL HAVE TO GO TO
KING COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH- THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE IS THAT-
IS THERE A CONCERN THAT IF THIS
BILL. PASSES AND IT WRAPS
AROUND. THE PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH
FACILITIES INCLUDED IN THE
COUNTIES WHERE THE COUNTY
SERVICES CONCERN IN ONE PART OF
IT IS BUDGETARY. BUT I THINK
THE MOST IMPORTANT PART IS THAT
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURERS AND-
INDIVIDUALS OF PRIVATE PAY. MAY
BE ABLE TO PUSH OUT OR USE
BEDS- THAT ARE OF LIMITED
SPACE. AS WE KNOW NOW- THAT FOR
MEDICAL. YOU KNOW MEDICATIONS.
SO I'M CURIOUS IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT ON THAT. ONE OF THE
CLARIFY IF I COULD- THERE ARE
NO TRANSFERS IF THERE IS NO
BAD. YOU KNOW WHAT PART OF ME
THERE IS NO TRANSFERRED IF
THERE IS NO BED SPACE
AVAILABLE. THAT'S THE ONLY
REASON THERE'S A TRANSFER IS
THERE'S AN OPEN BED AVAILABLE.
AT THAT POINT WE SIMPLY. WANT
THEM TO SELECTED WITHOUT
LOOKING AT THEIR ABILITY TO PAY.
I APPRECIATE THAT I GUESS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IT LIKE WE
HAVE ONE SIXTEEN BED FACILITY
AND LET'S JUST SAY THAT. EIGHT
BEDS ARE FILLED WITH PRIVATE
PAY AND EIGHT BEDS ARE FILLED
WITH- WITH- INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE THEIR OWN HEALTH PLAN. IN
THE COUNTY CALLS AND SAYS WE
HAVE A PERSON ON ME TO MEDICAL
OR WHATEVER THEY SAY TO
TRANSFER A BED. I THINK THAT-
REQUIRING THIS COULD. YOUR
DOCTOR OR AN EMERGENCY ROOM
DOCTOR AND DOCTOR PAN IS ALSO A
PHYSICIAN- SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO CONVEY- THE CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE THAT MY COUNTY HAS SHARED
WITH ME AND YOU SEE NO. ISSUES
WITH THAT WHATSOEVER OF SPACE
BEING FILLED UP WITH OTHER THAN
MEDICAL PATIENTS FOR. COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH CENTER AND WE USE
YOUR EXAMPLE IF WE COULD YOU
HIGHLIGHTED SIXTEEN. PEOPLE TO
FEEL SIXTEEN BEDS THERE WOULD
BE NO OPEN SPACE FOR A TRANSFER
TO GO TO THAT FACILITY. NOW IF
THERE HAPPENS TO BE AN OPEN
SPACE I THINK. THE BILL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU TODAY WOULD SIMPLY
ASK THAT THAT SPACE NOT BE
JUDGED BASED ON THEIR ABILITY
TO PAY. BUT SIMPLY SEE IT AS A
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE DUE TO THE
EMERGENCY PSYCHIATRIC CONDITION
THAT THEY'RE IN. I AGAIN AND
MAYBE I'M JUST MISLEAD MISSING
AND I DON'T MEAN TO KEEP
CIRCLING BACK I AGREE. I AGREE
THAT THEY SHOULD NOT BE JUDGED%
ON THEIR ABILITY TO PAY THE
BILL BEFORE ME I UNDERSTAND AND
I AGREE WITH THAT AS A MTTER
OF FACT I'VE- VOTED FOR IN THE
PAST. BUT THIS NEW CONCERN WITH
THE HEIGHTS- PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH
FACILITIES. THE PROBLEM IS THAT.
IF SECRETARY HEALTH FACILITIES
WERE NOT IN THERE THEN- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT MEDICAL
PATIENTS WOULD BE PLACED THERE.
AND NOT SO MUCH A PRIVATE PAYER
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE THEY
WOULD GO TO. AN OTHER
FACILITIES OTHER THAN COUNTY
PROVIDED FACILITIES IS THAT NOT
TRUE. I'M NOT SURE I'M TRACKING
EVERY PART OF YOUR EXAMPLE
THERE RIGHT. I WOULD- MORE
LIKELY POINTS TO WHAT DOCTOR
EGGMAN HAD BROUGHT UP WHICH IS
THE LACK OF NECESSARY BEDS FOR.
US AS A STATE TO ADDRESS THIS.
THUS THE LEADERSHIP THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE STATE IS
PROVIDING TO INVEST INTO THESE
CONTINUANCE OF CARE MAY
SUPPLEMENT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FROM THE POLICY DECISION WHICH
IS BEFORE US TODAY WHICH IS
SEPARATE AND ALL THE BUDGETARY-
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS THAT
WE'RE HEARING AS WELL. OKAY I
GUESS LIKE I SAID THAT IF THE
FACILITY IS FULL WITH PRIVATE
PAID AND THERE WOULD BE NO ROOM
FOR MEDICARE PATIENTS AND THEN
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM- ARE
THEY JUST ALLOWED HER TO REMAIN
IN THE HOSPITAL SO THERE'S NO
TRANSFER THEY STAY
HOSPITALIZED. WHEN I WAS IN THE
E. R. IF I WAS NOT ABLE TO FIND
A HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE THEY
WOULD STAY IN THE E. R. INTO WE
FOUND. THEM THE CARE THEY WOULD
NEED AND REQUIRE. AND OFTEN
TIMES THE EMERGENCY ROOM IS NOT
THE BEST PLACE FOR THOSE WHO
ARE SUFFERING WITH AN EMERGENCY
PSYCHIATRIC CONDITION TO
LANGUISH IN SET FOR DAYS ON
END. AND BELIEVE THAT IF WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEND
THEM TO A HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE
BECAUSE OF THAT IS AVAILABLE.
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
PASSED POLICY. IN THAT VEIN AS
WELL OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT AND
LIKE I SAID I DO AGREE WITH-
MIKE CALLING FROM STOCKTON THAT
BROUGHT THIS UP WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH BEDS. AND I GUESS MY
CONCERN THE HUGE CONCERN THAT I
HAVE IS I ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COUNTIES THAT FEEL LIKE IF
THERE'S- SIXTEEN BEDS AND
THEY'RE ALL TAKEN BYPRIVATE
PAY THEN THERE WOULDN'T BE. ANY
ROOM FOR THOSE THAT- DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PAY AND THAT'S A
CONCERN THAT I HAVE AS WELL- I
DO HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION AND-
PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH FACILITIES-
INCLUSION IN THIS BILL.
ACTUALLY CREATED. OPPOSITION
FROM CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT. YOUR UNDERSTANDING AS
WELL OR NOT. CURRENTLY C. H. A.
AS IN ENOUGH. TO THE BILL. AND
THEY HAVEN'T HAD ANY
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU ABOUT
BEING IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
NOT IN THIS VERSION OF THE BILL
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON THAT
OKAY. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING MY
QUESTIONS. RIGHT THANK YOU
SERA. THANK YOU MR CHAIR YOU
KNOW I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
PROBLEMS WITH. THE LACK OF
MENTAL EALTH BEDS. IN THE
STATE IN FACT IT'S A TRAGEDY
THAT WE HAVEN'T. ADDRESSED THAT
ISSUE. AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM WITH THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES I HAVE A
QUESTION ACTUALLY OF- THE
OPPOSITION IF THEY'RE STILL ON
THE LINE. MISTER CHAIR. YES IT
CAN WE PLEASE BRING ON TYLER-
RIND A RANDY- BACK ON THE LINE.
THE SURGERY. YES THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE THERE I'D I'D JUST LIKE
TO REALLY TRY TO CLARIFY THE
OPPOSITION IS IT YOUR POSITION
THAT YOU WANT TO HOLD A VACANT
BED IN A PSYCHIATRIC FACILITY.
FOR A MEDIC HELP PATIENT SO IF
THERE IS A REFERRAL FROM AN
EMERGENCY ROOM. EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT PHYSICIAN AND THE
PATIENT IS NOT MEDICARE ALL YOU
WOULD PREFER TO NOT TAKE THAT
PATIENT IS THAT IT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION BETTER ROCK-
I WOULD LIKE THAT YOU KNOW
RESPONDED SAYING THAT THERE IS
YOU KNOW COUNTRY FALL YOU MIGHT
NEED FOR AND THERE'S A SHORTAGE
OF BAD. I THINK I MIGHT ADD HI
YOU KNOW. UNDERGROUND THAT WE
WOULD AT SAY THAT OUR
FACILITIES ARE SPECIALIZED FOR
THE MEDICARE POPULATION IN THAT
YOU SEE IN OUR RESORT. FOR THE
POPULATION THAT COUNTY
RESPONSIBLE FOR AND THAT WE HAD
YOU KNOW BUILT OUT THERE AFTER
THE ORDER Q. FAIL OR FEDERAL
BIRTH BY HAVING A PRIVATELY
INSURED INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
FACILITY. EVEN WITHOUT ON IT
THAT YOU KNOW OPPORTUNITY TO
GUIDE HOW THE CLOCK REMEMBER BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE CAN
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS. AND
APOLOGIZE I'M HEARING A LITTLE
FEEDBACK. WELL IF THAT I
THOUGHT THAT WE YOUR POSITION.
YOU HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT IDEA
BEFORE I CAME TO THIS BODY I
SERVED ON A FEW HOSPITAL BOARDS
OVER THE YEARS SINCE I'M PRETTY
OLD. AND I RECALL BEING ON A
HOSPITAL BOARD AT ONE POINT IN
TIME WHERE WE TOOK A PATIENT
INTO THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
WHO IS AN ADULT PATIENT.
FRANKLY THE SON OF A FRIEND OF
MINE. WHO ATTEMPTED TO COMMIT
SUICIDE BY DRINKING ANTIFREEZE.
PATIENT IS STABILIZED OBVIOUSLY
HAD A MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEM-
FOR AS I RECALL TWO WEEKS IN
THE HOSPITAL COULD NOT FIND A
MENTAL HEALTH BED IN WHICH TO
DIRECT THE PATIENT. THE ACUTE
CARE FACILITY WAS NOT LICENSED
TO PROVIDE PSYCHIATRIC CARE YET
ATTEMPTED TO CARE FOR THE
PATIENT- IN A ROOM WITH A
TWENTY FOUR HOUR WATCH THAT AS
I RECALL AT LEAST AT THE TIME
WAS REQUIRED UNFORTUNATELY.
STUFFHAPPENS IN THE PATIENT-
SLIPPED OUT OF THE ROOM WENT TO
THE FIRE EXIT ON THE SEVENTH OR
EIGHTH FLOOR THE FACILITY.
MANAGED TO DO WHAT THE ANTI
FREEZE COULD NOT DO. AND
FINISHED THE JOB AND COMMITTED
SUICIDE FOR LACK OF A MENTAL
HEALTH BED SO IF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS WE ARE TO HOLD VACANT
BEDS. BECAUSE OF THE PAY OR WHO
IS GOING TO BE PROVIDING THE
PAYMENT FOR THE SERVICE.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE FAIL
TO DO OUR JOB IN THE STATE BY
PROVIDING A SUFFICIENT NUMBER
OF MENTAL HEALTH BEDS AND
PERHAPS WE FAILED TO DO OUR JOB
LIKE. STRAIGHTENING OUT OUR
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO KEEP BEDS VACANT
WAITING FOR THE KIND OF
PATIENTS THAT YOU WANT TO
SERVICE WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE
BEDS AVAILABLE AND IF THERE'S A
PATIENT THAT NEEDS A BED THE
PATIENT NEEDS TO BE DIRECTED
THERE. SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANKS THANK YOU
ARE THERE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SEEING NONE- COUPLE
ACTUALLY DOES NOT MAKE A COUPLE
POINTS AS WELL AND AGAIN-
REALLY PUT US A MEMBER OF
RANDALL  DOCTRINE BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I KNOW THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME. I DO WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT- I THINK THERE MAY
HAVE BEEN SOME QUESTIONS
EARLIER AND THE DIALOGUE THAT.
PREVIOUS VERSIONS AS WELL THIS
VERSION INCLUDES THE COUNTY
PSYCHIATRIC- HEALTH FACILITIES
ARE SO SOMETIMES KNOWN AS
PUFFS- IN FACT THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION- BECAUSE IT
INCLUDES THOSE IS- IT IS NOT
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL PREVIOUS
CASES THEY HAVE ACTUALLY OPPOSE
BILLS WHICH DID INCLUDE THOSE
PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH FACILITIES
THE ONES THAT. I THINK THE
ROUTE DIRECTORS ASKING TO
ACTUALLY REMOVE SITES ONE MAKE
THAT CLEAR. YES I THINK THERE
WAS SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
HOSPITALIZATION AND THEIR
POSITIONS SO MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION'S
POSITIONS THEY NEED TO BE
INCLUDED- WHICH IS THE LOCUS OF
THE OPPOSITION- I WOULD ALSO
SAY IS THAT. IT IS AND THAT HE
WAS POINTED OUT BY- BY- CENTER
ADMIN AND ALSO SENT A ROSTER
THAT. YOU KNOW WE AND ALSO
CENTER AROUND LOW I MEAN UP THE
FINAL PROBLEMS WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH BEDS. THE QUESTION THEN
IS THAT WHEN THERE IS A BED
OPEN DO YOU JUST HOLD IT OPEN
BECAUSE- THE PERSON DOESN'T
HAVE THE RIGHT INSURANCE AND I
GET IT. THE COUNTY'S. CREATED
THE SIXTEEN BED FACILITY IS TO
BE SURE WE COULD BILL MEDICARE
RIGHT BECAUSE THE MEDICAL RULES
YOU CAN'T SOMETHING LARGE AND
SIXTEEN BEDS. AND SO- YOU KNOW
AND I UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERN
THAT WELL IS THIS PATIENT ME
NOT NECESSARY HAVE MEDIC COW.
WHO COULD GO TO ANOTHER
FACILITY BUT THOSE FACILITIES
ARE FULL NOW AND UP IN OUR
FACILITY. NOW THERE'S NO BAD
LEFT AT ALL. BUT YET THEY'RE
NOT USING IT. AND YES WE DON'T
KNOW WHEN SOMEONE MIGHT NEED.
THAT BAD IN THE FUTURE BUT-
THEN THE ISSUE DOWN TO I THINK
CENTER. THE SCHOOL THIS IS THAT
ARE WE JUST HOLD. END OF
SHORTAGE OF HOLDING. FOR SOME
TIME ON CERTAIN. WAITING FOR
SOMEONE TO ACTUALLY MEETS THE
BILLING QUALIFICATIONS INSTEAD
OF ACTUALLY PROVIDING CARE TO
SOMEONE WHO TRULY NEED STATS.
AND CERTAINLY I THINK WELL IT
AND I THINK- DO YOU- THAT. YOU
KNOW WE PROBABLY NEED TO
CONVERT ALL WE NEED MORE BEDS-
I THINK CENTER ADMISSION AT THE
CASE OF LEGISLATION FOR
REGISTRY SO WE HAVE A BETTER
SENSE- AND DEAL AND DESPITE
TRANSFERS UP TO HAVE TO TAKE
PLACE BUT FUNDAMENTALLY I THINK
THE POLICY ISSUE IS THAT-
SHOULD SOMEONE BE ABLE TO GET A
BED IF THERE'S A BAD THAT'S-
OPEN OR DO WE SIMPLY SAY NO WE
CAN DO A- CENTRALLY I.
INSURANCE CHECK AND IF YOU'RE
AN IRONICALLY IF YOU'RE NOT IN
THAT ACCOUNT USES THE OTHER WAY
AROUND. YOU'RE NOT MEDICARE YOU
CAN GET THE BAD AND- THEREFORE
YOU HAVE TO WAIT- SO- SO
CERTAINLY I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL- AND THIS POLICY AND-
SUMMER AND LIVED LIKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND- IF
I WILL I'LL TAKE SENATOR ROTH.
STATEMENT AS MICHAEL'S. OKAY
THANK YOU- YEAH ACTUALLY I DID
WAS- MOTION YET ON THE BILL
OKAY- CENTER ADMIN CENTER ADMIN
HAS MOVED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST. BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HAN HI. CAN I MELINDA'S
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I CAN SOLACE HI
AND SO AS I GROW. FOR TARO. FOR
TITLE I LEAVE I LEAVE I LEAVE
ALONE HI THE MON I ROSS. ROSS I
RUBIO HI RUBIO I WINNER. WINNER
I. OKAY THE LOTUS NINE ZERO
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
THANKS VERY MUCH. RIGHT OUR
NEXT ITEM IS. IS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN FI SUMMER QUICK SILVER-
BUT I UNDERSTAND SIR EDMUND
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON HER
BEHALF ALL RIGHT AND YOU WILL
BE DOING THAT FROM YOUR DESK
OKAY SIR EDMUND AGAIN THIS IS
EIGHTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT BY
SUMMER QUIRKS QUICKSILVER.
OKAY- THIS BILL BUILDS ON WORK
DONE LAST YEAR THERE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN SOME CONFUSION AROUND
ISSUES AROUND PARITY WITH
MENTAL HEALTH. AND IN THIS. IT
WAS THE PEOPLE THAT THINK THAT
YOU CAN USE A MIDDLE HEALTH
SERVICES ACTED TO TREAT PEOPLE
WITH THE COAL OCCURRING.
DISORDER THAT THAT WAS SOLVED
LAST YEAR BY A BILL SAYING THAT
YOU COULD TREAT SOMEBODY WITH
A- MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE AND AS
WELL AS A SUBSTANCE USE ISSUE.
WE KNOW THOSE THINGS OFTEN GO
HAND IN HAND THIS BILL TAKES IT
A STEP FURTHER. AND SAYS TO
FURTHER CLARIFY THAT IN SOME OF
THE EARLY PREVENTION OF MONEY
USED FOR THAT IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. THAT MONEY
CAN ALSO BE USED FOR PEOPLE
WITH THE SUBSIDIES ISSUE OR
COLD CURRENT DISORDERS- SO THAT
IS THE BILL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
BUT WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT AND
WE HAVE- WAS A GLORY FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF- THE- BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. I HAVE MY NOTES RIGHT
IN FRONT OF ME SO I AM. A
CARROT SOMEBODY ELSE'S BILL. AS
WELL AS- DR. KEEP IT OUTSIDE.
FOR ME TONIGHT DANOVICH. YES
THE FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH RAIDER- PLEASE BRING ON TO
THE LINE FOR TESTIFIED FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT DR A TIGHT
DANOVICH FROM. HIS COMMISSIONER
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AND- WELL I GOTTA GO
AND I COME FROM THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA I DO
HAVE. DR DANOVICH IS BEING THE
FIRST TEST OF FIRE BUT IF I AM
INCORRECT- LET ME KNOW BUT I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN WITH DR DANOVICH
AND AGAIN YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TOTAL FOR MINUTES
BETWEEN THE BOTH OF YOU. THANK
YOU. THERE REMEMBER. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME IS
IDENTIFIED. I AM GETTING A
SUBSTANTIAL ECHO ON THE LINE
SO- COUNTRY WHERE THAT IS
GENERATED FROM. I'M PROFESSOR
AND CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PSYCHIATRY AND BEHAVIORAL
NEUROSCIENCES AT CEDAR SINAI
AND CONTINENTAL US. I AM A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE AND PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE. AND AS YOU
HEARD I SERVE ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION I'M
HERE TO SPEAK WITH PORT OF
EIGHTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT I WANT
TO THANK THE FAMILY MEMBER
THANKS A LOT FOR HER LEADERSHIP
ON ACROSS MENTAL HEALTH AND
STUFF. THE SPEEDS IN PRAGUE
DURING THIS BILL. A. B. SIX
THIRTY EIGHT AUTHORIZES THE USE
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING. FOR PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION STRATEGIES.
TO ADDRESS SUBSTANCE ABUSE. AS
WELL AS MENTAL HEALTH CODE
DURING THE SHORT. BUT THE
PSYCHIATRIST. I WANT TO
PRESERVE ALL THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO MEDICAL CONDITION.
FULL STOP BUT I THINK THIS LAW
IS NECESSARY FOR THREE REASONS.
FIRST SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERIS
A MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION. IN
MY CLINICAL PRACTICE I
REGULARLY SEE THAT THESE
TECHNICIANS ARE CONNECTED
THEY'RE LINKED. THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE FAMILY OR FRIENDS WITH
ADDICTION I'M SURE YOU SEE THE
SAME. THE DISTINCTION IN OUR
POLICIES. IS A RELIC OF AN
OUTDATED UNDERSTANDING. THE
SCIENCE IS VERY CLEAR ON THE
SENATE WHY ACROSS THE BOARD IN
PSYCHIATRY THERE'S AN INTEGRATE
MODEL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
SERVICES. SECOND USE IT AS A
MAJOR COMPLICATING FACTORS
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
IT'S ASSOCIATED WITH FORCED
RESPONSE WRITTEN. MORE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND MUCH FOR
COVERAGE. PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS DIED AFTER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS EARLIER THAN
NORMAL AND GOOD CONTRIBUTOR TO
THIS IS TO USE ALCOHOL USE
ILLICIT DRUG USE IN OVERTIME.
HAVING SEPARATE FROM SUBSTANCE
USE AND MENTAL HEALTH JUST
BEING PUT THROUGH THE CRACKS.
AND THIRD. EARLY IN LIFE. FIVE
TIME REST OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS. FOR INSTANCE AMONG
KIDS WITH A VULNERABILITY TO
DEVELOP SCHIZOPHRENIA TO MAKE
REALLY USED TO CANNABIS
INCREASE. WHEN IT COMES TO
PREVENTION AND- REALLY FOR
CHILDREN. SEPARATE MENTAL
HEALTH AND- PASSING A B. SIX
THIRTY EIGHT THANK THEM TO
ADMIT A BIT HUMOROUS TACTICIAN
NURSES ARE. IMPROVE TOOLS WE
SERVE ONE HALF MYSELF WITH MY
PORT. EIGHTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTION AT.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL NOW MOVE TO ALASKA-
ALTHOUGH FROM THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION JUST BE SURE YOU
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON THAT MAY I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S THE PROBLEM HE
FEEDBACK BUT- AGAIN ALIAH. GADO
PLEASE. AND YOU HAVE A MINUTE
THANK YOU DR TAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ONLY AVAILABLE WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR. ATION WHICH
REPRESENTS THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAMS. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE ARE SUPPORT FOR A.
B. THREE FOR EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK
SILVA AND THANK SENATOR ADMIN
FOR PRESENTING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. IT'S STILL A CRIME AND IS
ALIGNED WITH THE STATED PURPOSE
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT. TO DEFINE SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS AMONG CHILDREN ADULTS
AND SENIORS AT THE CONDITION
DESERVING PRIORITY ATTENTION
INCLUDING PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES HAD
STATED BY DOCTOR DAMAGE. BUT
SINCE HE'S THE STARTER IS A
MENTAL ILLNESS THAT'S
RECOGNIZED BY THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF MENTAL HEALTH. AND
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE ON DRUG
ABUSE AS WELL AS THE DIAGNOSTIC
AND STATISTICAL STATISTICAL
MANUAL ON MENTAL DISORDERS.
DANDER CLASSIFICATION OF MENTAL
DISORDERS USED IN CLINICAL
RESEARCH POLICY AND
REIMBURSEMENT. AND WHICH IS
RECOGNIZED AS TWO D. AS A
PSYCHIATRIC DISORDER IS SYMPTOM
OF A PSYCHIATRIC DISORDERS
INCIDENT INCEPTION. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. RECOGNIZE THAT
WITH TO. A CD OR SOMETHING TO
SEND. ANY OTHER HEALTH
CONDITION YOU'D LIKE IT GO AND-
AS HE DID IN THE ANALYSIS MOST
INDIVIDUALS CONCERNED BY
COUNTY. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM HAS IT FOR
THOSE THAT ARE YOU BEING SERVED
PRESS STEPS INTO SUPPORTERS
MOST OF THEM HAVE A CO
OCCURRING OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. FOR ADOLESCENTS A
TARGET POPULATION PREVENT FOR
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION FUND THE RECENT
COLD CURRENT DISORDERS OR EVEN
HIGHER SAM AND NOES THAT MERRY
GO IN ANY ADOLESCENT STDS.
PROBLEMS EXIST WITHOUT ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION BEING RESIDENT HAS
WRAPPED UP. SUFFERING FROM ANTI
D. SIGNIFICANTLY INHIBITS THE
DIAGNOSIS OF OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS AND FOR ALL
THESE REASONS CAN YOU BE HERE
HOLD DIRECTORS STATEWIDE
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT FOR A. B.
SIX THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
EIGHT TO BEGIN WITH PUBLIC
GALLERY SINGLE AT THE PUBLIC
GALLONS MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR. PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF.
EIGHTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU AT THE- LADIES AND-
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN. OF ABC
THIRTY. THIS PRESS ONE THERE
ARE. AN OPERATOR WILL WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. BUT AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BABY.
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO THEIR OWN NOW. IT IS TIME
FOR SURE WEHAVE ONE PERSON IN
Q. ALL RIGHT MY NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO M NAME IS MY
EVERYTHING AND UNDERSTOOD IT
BUT I AM LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE. FOR THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. AT THE TIME OF
THE YEAR THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH. A MODERATOR WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD WITNESS
OPPOSITION WITNESS TO TESTIFY
SO WILL THEN MOVE ON TO
DISTILLATES AS AN- OPPOSITION
TO EIGHTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT
LET'S MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON PUBLIC ALEX
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SCENE ON ONE TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TO A B. SIX
THIRTY EIGHT. NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY THINK MEDICARE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTEEN. THIRTY EIGHT. THE
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL.
GREAT I WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH.
A NUMBER OF COMPLETED BACK IN
JUNE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHT.
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. AT THIS
TIME A TEACHER WE HAVE NO MONEY
Q. OKAY THANKS SO MUCH
MODERATOR WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENT
RUBIO. THANK YOU MR CHAIR- I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I DID
HEAR THE COMMENTS FROM YOUR
WITNESSES AND- HEY IT'S REALLY-
AN IMPORTANT BILL AS STATED
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER. NOW
RECOGNIZED AS A MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER AND THE REALITY IS
THAT I AGREE WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS YOU CAN'T NECESSARILY
TREAT ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER.
BOTH ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND ESPECIALLY THAT. NOW THAT
WE KNOW ALL THIS LAST YEAR HAS
CHALLENGED SO MANY INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ALREADY DEALING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS AND NOW
ARE. YOU KNOW I'M- TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THAT HAS TIME OFF
TO REALLY INCREASE THE
SUBSTANCE USE SO NOW I FEEL
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO DO. I KNOW THAT THERE'S
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FUNDING
BEING DIMINISHED HOWEVER THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE ACTUALLY
NEED TO DO. EARLY PREVENTION
AND INTERVENTION IS KEY TO ANY
DISEASE DISORDER OR OR ELEMENT
SO I FULL HEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THIS AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND I
WOULD MAKE HE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU BILLS AND MOVE BY SENATOR
RUBIO. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE- IN US SIR EDMUND
PRECEDE YOU TESTIFY I'M
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF SUMMER
QUICK SILVER I THINK THIS IS-
FORTIN BILL. THAT DRESSES THAT
JURORS THAT WE CAN USE OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
MONEY TO HELP. ADDRESS
SUBSTANCE USE I'D I'D CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND SOME THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS FROM SOME PEOPLE THAT
THEY THINK THIS. LOOTS OUT THE
MONEY BUT I WOULD I WOULD POINT
OUT THIS I THINK YOU'VE ALSO
THIS MANY PEOPLE POINTED OUT TO
US SUBSTANCE USE AND MENTAL
HEALTH ARE SO INTERLINKED
AFFECT SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
ARE. MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS IN
ITSELF AND I THINK THERE FOR-
MEETS THE INTENT OF THE
ORIGINAL ACT WITH THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE O CLOSE. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AT. SOME REMEMBER
QUICKSILVER HAS BEEN A LEADER
IN THIS AREA. AND CERTAINLY HAS
BEEN PUBLIC ABOUT SHARING SOME
STRUGGLES IN HER OWN FAMILY IN
THIS PEOPLE MAY KNOW SHE HAD A
BROTHER WITH A COOKERY
DISORDERS. WHO ENDED UP BEING
HIT BY A CAR AND- AND DYING ON
OUR STREETS AND SO- AND FOR
SHARING QUICK SOUTHERN FOR HER
BROTHER BILLY I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE. I
THANK YOU SO THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR RUBIO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI CAN
I MELINDA'S. AIKMAN HI EIGHT
MEN I CAN SOLACE. HI CONSOLES I
GROW HER TADO ON HER TADO HI
LISA. HI LEAVE A I. LI MON. LEE
MON I ROSS HI RUSS I RUBIO. HI
RUBIO I WINNER. BY WINNER I.
OKAY SO THAT BILL IS- CURRENTLY
NINE ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY NINE THE
SIMMONS ARIAN WELCOME. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON. COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE
TO FIRST START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
COLLABORATION ON THIS MEASURE-
WE DO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO ADD A SUNSET
AFTER TEN YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THE
AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW FOR ANOTHER
ENTITY TO PROVIDE COMPATIBLE
CERTIFICATION. AS APPROVED BY
CDPH. CALIFORNIA REQUIRES EVERY
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY OR
SNAPS TO EMPLOY A MEDICAL
DIRECTOR WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF. RESIDENT
CARE POLICIES AND THE
COORDINATION OF MEDICAL CARE IN
THIS NOV. EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE WOULD PROHIBIT A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY FROM
CONTRACTING WITH A PERSON AS A
MEDICAL DIRECTOR IF THE PERSON
IS NOT. OR WILL NOT BE WITHIN
FIVE YEARS CERTIFIED THROUGH
THE AMERICAN POST ACUTE. AND
LONG TERM CARE MEDICINE AS A
CERTIFIED MEDICAL DIRECTOR OR
WITH TODAY'S AMENDMENTS
CERTIFIED BY A COMPATIBLE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM APPROVED
BY CDPH. HAS A POINTED OUT BY
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
CHAIR THIS IS OUTSIDE OF THE
STANDARD OF CARE WE COULDN'T
AGREE MORE. THE STANDARD OF
CARE IS INSUFFICIENT AND THE
STANDARD OF CARE DID NOT SERVE
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA'S ELDERS. DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
UNDERSTAND OUR SHARED INTENT.
OF IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS MOVING FORWARD.
THIS BILL INCREASES
ACCOUNTABILITY COST THE STATE
NOTHING AND PROFESSIONAL EYES
IS A POSITION OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE. AGING CALIFORNIANS
AND OUR MOST FRAIL LIVING IN
SNAPS HAVE BEEN A TRAGIC
HIGHLIGHT OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THIEVES HAVE
ACCOUNTED FOR A MINOR
PERCENTAGE OF CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT VIRUS CASES BUT A FAR
GREATER PERCENTAGE OF ITS
DEATHS. WHILE COLONEL VIRUS IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE THAT'S
THE UNDERLYING CAUSES THAT
ALLOWED FOR THE INORDINATE
NUMBER OF DEATHS AMONGST
RESIDENTS. AND STAFF HAVE BEEN
IN EVIDENT AND- FOR DECADES
RESEARCH IN THE AREAS OF
STAFFING PROTOCOLS INFECTION
PREVENTION AND OUT OF THE
FUNDING MECHANISMS. HAVE LED TO
AN INDUSTRY THAT NEEDS GREATER
STRUCTURES IN PLACE TO DELIVER
A CARE MODEL THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE SAFE AND ABLE TO
MEET DEMAND AS NEEDED. MEDICAL
DIRECTORS AND SNIFFS CAN BETTER
SERVE AGING CALIFORNIANS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES LIVING
IN CONGREGATE CARE SETTINGS BY
HAVING THE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
THAT COMES WITH CERTIFICATION.
WITH ME ON THE PHONE LINES
TODAY SUPPORTING- A. B. SEVEN
FORTY NINE OUR DOCTORS MICHAEL
WASSERMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF. LONG TERM CARE
MEDICINE AND BHAJI ON PARO.
MEDICAL CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER
WITH NEW GEN HEALTH AT THIS
BILL HAS- HAD TO UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF SOUTHERN
SYRIAN MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ON THE LINE DR MICHAEL
WASSERMAN FROM CALIFORNIA SO
SEASON LONG TERM CARE MEDICINE
AND- BUT YOU IN PARO FROM NEW
GEN HEALTH. I BELIEVE THAT
START WITH DR WASSERMAN YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER- SO WE
CAN. BRING ON DR WASSERMAN
FIRST. OUR MISSION CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
GOING TO MY COLLECTION AND I
REPRESENTED CALIFORNIA LOCATION
OF. ADDISON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE- FORTY NINE.
TODAY'S NURSING HOME START
SCHEDULING MANY HOSPITAL.
LANDING THE ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT
OF MEDICAL DIRECTORS WITH
CLINICAL REGULATORY BIOETHICS
AND MANAGEMENT EXPERTISE. ON MY
**** BECAUSE NURSING HOMES HAVE
DON'T REQUIRE ME TO FORMAL
CREDENTIALING MEDICAL STAFF
ORGANIZATION BY FEDERAL
REGULATION PROPHETICAL
DIRECTORY LISTS THAT WE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
MEDICAL CHARACTERS. INCLUDING
PARTICIPATION. IN QUALITY
ASSURANCE. SADLY MANY NURSING
HOMES MEDICAL DIRECTORS PROVEN
TO BE LOOKED WE ARE PREPARED TO
DO THAT JUST REQUIRING MEDICAL
ATTENTION. PROVIDED CLEAR
RECOGNITION OF THEIR VALUE WITH.
OVER NINE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS DIED
DURING AMERICAN. AS AN EXPERT
IN GERIATRIC MEDICINE. QUALITY
MADE FORMER NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY EXECUTIVES I BELIEVE
WE COULD HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE. MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
MUST MAKE A DIFFERENCE GOING
FORWARD TO DEDICATE A WIDE YOU.
CAN REVIEW PAPERS AND INDUSTRY
EXPERTS ACKNOWLEDGE THE VALUE
OF COMPETENT. ENGAGE BETTER
DIRECT. CHABLIS HAVING MEDICAL
DIRECTORS GUILD TOMORROW TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE. ALL CARE
NURSING HOME IS NOT THE
STANDARD OF CARE. WE CAN NO
LONGER HOLD IT THE RIGHT THING.
ON ITS OWN ACCORD. IT'S TIME
YOU REQUIRED IT ALSO SHOULD
NOT. BE CERTIFIED. TESTING
CERTIFICATION QUOTE THAT VISION
WAS FOLLOWED NOT A GOOD ALMOST.
DO NOT PROVIDE AND SKILLS
NECESSARY TO BE PREPARED FOR
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
COORDINATING MEDICAL CARE IN A
NURSING HOMEIN THE WAKE OF THE
TRAGIC OUTCOME TO THE COLD.
YEAH I THINK. I'M PRETTY. SURE
LAST. RIGHT THANK YOU TO IT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU AND AGAIN I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER THIS IS A
SITUATION- BUT PLEASE- WILL
CARRY SOME FEEDBACK SO JUST BE
SURE YOU MUTE THE DEVICE ON
WHICH YOU'RE WATCHING THIS
HEARING ON WHEN YOU GIVE
TESTIMONY SO TRY TO AVOID
CUSICK FEEDBACK I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT WAS THE CASE OR NOT. LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO- BUT GM PERO.
YEAH BUT AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO OFFER MY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. EIGHTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE. I'VE BEEN IN
A LONG TERM CARE INDUSTRY FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. AND I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE BY BACKGROUND
EARLY IN THE ROLE OF CHIEF
CLINICAL OFFICER OVERSEEING
THIRTY FIVE FIELD NURSING
FACILITY IN CALIFORNIA
WASHINGTON AND NEVADA COMBINED
BEING IN A VARIETY OF NURSING
ROLES IN A STILL NURSING
FACILITY. READING ALOUD IN
WITNESSED FIRST HAND HOW THE
ROLE OF THE MEDICAL. THANK YOU
THE DEMAND FOR THEIR INTIMATE
ENGAGEMENT IN THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS BECAME APPARENT AND
VERY CHALLENGING AT THE SAME
TIME SEVEN HANDS ON TRAINING AS
A MEDICAL. DIRECTORY NEXT
BETTING IN ALL REQUIRING
CERTIFICATION AS A MEDICAL
DIRECTOR AND A FOUNDING PROGRAM
OFFEREDBY THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
AND ON YOUR MEDICARE. PLAN THAT
YOU KNOW THEY'RE SINKS.
INDUSTRY THAT MUCH NEEDED- HE'S
BEEN DEAD DRIVING A BETTER
BEING PATIENT AND RESIDENT
CLINICAL OUTCOMES THE LACK OF
BASIC KNOWLEDGE INVOLVING I
DON'T THINK THE PUBLIC
RELATIONS. THE MEDICAL GROUP
PRODUCT FOR THE LACK OF
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT OF THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR INVOLVING
COMPLEXITIES OF CARE REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE AND CLINICAL
OUTCOMES. IN A NURSING FACILITY
CURRENTLY REGARDED AS BEING
EXTENSION OF THE ACUTE HOSPITAL
WILL CONTINUE TO PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
AND THE NEED FOR A WELL VERSED
BUILD NURSING FACILITY MEDICAL
DIRECTOR IT'S ABSOLUTELY GOING
TO BE A VITAL COMPONENT. TO
MEET THE DEMAND. FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY BEDS. THE
EIGHTEEN CAL. AND THE PRESSURE
ON. THE PATIENT. AND OUR THE OR
THINGS CREDIT CLINTON OUTCOMES.
WE CAN ONLY. BE WAY WHEN I NEED
FOR A COMPETENT AND HIGHLY
ENGAGED MEDICAL DIRECTOR. I
HOPE MY TENURE AND EXPERIENCE
IN THE INDUSTRY BUT PAID NO WAY
CAN BE HEARD AND TRIGGER AN
INDELIBLE CHANGED MARKET.
INDUSTRY I NEED TO HAVE A
HIGHLY ENGAGED AND WELL TRAINED
MEDICAL DIRECTORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PERFECT TIMING ALL
RIGHT SO- WITH THAT WERE MOVED
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE WILL BEGIN WITH THE PUBLIC
GALLERY SCENE ON THE PUBLIC
ALICE MISSOURI TWENTY FORTY
SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR. PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU AT THE AND MADE IT
INTO. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK AT
THE POINT OF EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE. LONDON ZERO NOW. WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU'RE PUTTING OUT A COAST
VISION OF REGIONAL FEDERATION
PLEASE OPEN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
EXLINE. AT THE TIME A TEACHER
THAT'S THE ONLY ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANKS FOR MUCH MODERATOR
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION LISTED FOR TESTIMONY
SO WE CAN MOVE TO DIFFERENT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION BEGAN
WITH THE PUBLIC GALLERY SCENE
ON THE PUBLIC ALLEY IT'S MOVED
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY C. KNOWN
TODAY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SEVEN
FORTY NINE. NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF EIGHTY SEVEN
FORTY NINE. THAT'S ONE ZERO.
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AGAIN IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IN.
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY NINE. THAT'S
ONE ZERO NOW. AND THAT IS KIND
OF FUTURE WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY SEEM LIKE THE BUT THAT
LET'S MOVE TO BRING ABOUT. THE
SPRING BACK TO COMMITTEE OR THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- DON'T SEE
ANYONE. OKAY WELL- NOT SEEING
ANY- SO SIMMONS ARIAN FIRST OF
ALL I WANT THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- REALLY
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THIS BILL-
TO RAISE THE STANDARDS. FOR A
MEDICAL DIRECTORS I THINK THE
CONCERN WHICH YOU ARE DRESSING
LIKE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS IS
THAT- FROM I UNDERSTAND.
UNFORTUNATE RIGHT NOW ONLY A
MINORITY OF THE MATTER OF THE
MEDICAL DIRECTORS ACTUALLY MEET
THE STANDARD WILL BE SURE
THERE'S A SMOOTH TRANSITION
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
DESTRUCTION BUT CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH YOUR GOALS OF RAISING THAT
STANDARD. OVERALL TOO IN IN-
NURSING HOMES AND ALSO BE SURE
THAT- WE HAVE SOME MECHANISMS
IN CASE THERE'S SOME ISSUES
THAT COME UP WITH THIS
PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION WHICH I
HOPE. WON'T BE THE CASE BUT
JUST TO BE SURE SO- C. B. TWO
B. HAVE THAT ABILITY TO DO
THAT. SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU AND- I
GUESS THE ONLY PARTING THOUGHT
I'D LIVE LIKE TO JUST MENTION
IS. THAT LESS THAN 1% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION LIVES
IN LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES-
BUT AS OF MARCH OF THIS YEAR-
THEY ACCOUNTED 434% OF THE US.
US DEATHS DUE TO COVERT A
NINETEEN SO. THAT'S A PRETTY
PROFOUND STATISTIC WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IT THAT WAY AND- AND
THEN HUMANIZE. WHAT THOSE
NUMBERS MEAN TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IMPACTED BY THE LOSS OF
LIFE. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IPHONE
THINK TANK THANKS SO MUCH SAM
MEMBER- IT IS OUR MOTION FROM
ULTIMATE MOVE BY CENTER ADMIN
AND EMOTIONS DO PASSES AMENDED
BUT PLEASE. FIRST WE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND HI.
CAN I MELINDA'S. EGGMAN RIGHT
EIGHT WHEN I CAN CALL US HI
CONSOLES. OUR GROWTH FURTADO.
LISA HI LEAVE EILEEN MOANED. HI
THE MOON I ROTH FIVE ROTH IRA
RUBIO. HI RUBIO I WINNER FIVE
WINNER HI EIGHT. HURTADO RIGHT
NOW WHEN I TRY TO I. ZERO NINE
OKAY SO THE CURRENTLY THE
VOTERS NINE ZERO PUT THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY THANK YOU- WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AGAIN WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY TWO
BY SOME OF MY SENATOR COMMA
LAGER AND I'M NUMBER SIX EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY TWO BY SUMMER WOULD
ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY ONE FROM THE FAMILY
HEALTH COMMITTEE I AND NUMBER
TEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
FROM SIMPLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
AND ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBER CHANGES OUR MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY SO
MEMBER AT CENTURY CENTER FOR
ADMIN AND I'M GETTING BACK.
SEVEN THE ADMIN IS MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND HI CAN I
MELINDA'S EGGMAN EGGMAN I.
GONZALES HI AND SO AS I GROW
FURTADO HI FURTADO I LEYVA ALL
LIVE I LIVE ALONE HI THE MON I
ROTH. ROTH IRA RUBIO HI RUBIO I
WINNER WINNER HI OKAY CONSENT
CALENDAR IS CURRENTLY NINE ZERO
BUT THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON
CALL OKAY WITH THAT WE'LL GO GO
AHEAD AND- OPEN UP THE ROLE
FOR- BILLS THAT WE HAVE AND
IT'S ACTUALLY THE SERVICE
SOMEONE CAN JUST LET. I KNOW
THAT- CENTER GROVE IS IN- RULES
COMMITTEE BUSTLING SLUR NO THAT
WOULD SOON SHE'S ABLE TO COME
OVER HERE WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
OPEN A ROLE FOR HER AS WELL-
OKAY SO WILL AGAIN- BEGIN WITH
THAT. ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE BY SUMMER
DAVIES- CANCELED PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OFABSENT MEMBERS AND
AS THE MOM. HI LEON HI. OKAY
THAT BILL IS OUT TEN ZERO- NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY NINE
BASE SUMMER BERIKAN. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MELINDA'S
GROVE. OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM AND WELL YOU KNOW I
THINK FOR THE REST OF THEM WE
GOT EVERYONE COVERED. YEAH I
THINK IT'S OKAY. MY CAN TELL
SISTER CENTER GROVE IS THE ONLY
PERSON REMAINING SO- WITH THAT-
I WILL. AWAIT CENTER GROWTH BUT
OKAY. YES. BUT THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE. THAT'S.
ALL
RIGHT SO- AGAIN- WE'LL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN- FOR- FOR CENTER
GROVE WHO IS ALSO HAS ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO UNTIL SHE'S ABLE
TO- COME OVER WE WILL COLD CALL
A RECESS- FOR RIGHT NOW SO THIS
COMMITTEE IS IN RECESS.